le président Bruno retaillod a rapporté
des faits extérieurs à notre hémicycle
mais les a rapportés en s'adressant
manifestement directement au président
Kanner nous nous bataillons fermement
contre cette réforme nous utilisons ce
des outils que le règlement nous accorde
nous l'opposition mais nous ne sommes en
aucune manière responsable des faits
tout à fait regrettable et parfois
délictueux que le président Retailleau a
rapporté et parfois des luxueux que le
président Retailleau a rapporté il
serait bon que ces attaques personnelles
qui sont proscrites par l'article 33 de
notre règlement n'est pas lieu dans
cette hémicycle vous portez une réforme
nous l'avons compris vous l'avez conçu
cette réforme vous l'avez confiée au
gouvernement c'est un peu une gestation
pour autrui que vous avez fait une
gestation pour le gouvernement
et
l'accouchement est un peu difficile nous
en convenons retrouvons notre calme
cessons ces attaques et appliquons les
articles de notre règlement je vous
remercie
[Musique]